please welcome the one and only michelle
scifi
[Applause]
you know it's funny sometimes some
people will say like i know you i feel
like i know you and it's hard because
we're not very good at being objective
about ourselves but
i think we all feel that way about you
really yes absolutely
it's very surprising to hear you say
that because i'm a bit shy
and it comes off as being kind of icy
and aloof sometimes in fact that's
really primarily what i get
and i'm like really and um um but you
know so it's just it's very nice to hear
you say that well you definitely have an
alluring um mysterious quality um i'm
more of anxiety it's total anxiety i'm
telling you right now well this part
lays right into my first question which
is it's beauty week here and you
were you started in a beauty pageant
how do you talk yourself off the ledge
if you're having any anxiety to go out
there
and like knock them dead
you know it's that thing like performing
it's like any kind of performing it's
you can be
literally like vomiting you know in the
wings waiting to go and then the minute
the camera rolls or the minute
you walk on stage it's something else
takes over um but you know the first
10 years of acting the first day of
shooting
i would shake uncontrollably so bad and
i was i was convinced that you would be
able to see it on screen but fortunately
for me you never could i have a clip
from this 1978 pageant which i'm really
excited about because i know these
photographs very well they are burned in
my
memories but i've never seen moving
footage of it and we have it here so i
would love to show it
[Music]
hair
a high school graduate going to golden
west college
from orange county michelle pfeiffer
a softball player who also oil paints
she'd like to become an actress
i know
see
it just goes to show you it doesn't
matter where you start
now okay that was from the 1978 miss
california pageant um when you're
looking at that is there any memory that
comes to your head other than like maybe
the psyching yourself out on the
sidelines i went in doing this because i
was told that one of the judges was a
commercial agent and he had been known
to sign
people from the pageant and so that was
the whole reason i did it did anything
come out of that page yeah i actually
signed with the agency i started doing
commercials
i mean
not to sound creepy but like who
wouldn't who would not see you and not
be like back flip back flip back flip
back flip hi would you like to sign with
me
did he play it cool
yeah he did actually and they wanted me
to change my name though oh to what
anything but pfeiffer because nobody
could spell it the e i the double f it
was just all too much for them i guess
what made you stick to your guns about
that i'm kind of willful
um and i my father would have killed me
yes
good okay well this is good uh oh by the
way in what lies beneath is it true that
you maybe channeled yes casey becker
from stream
what is that
what
[Music]
what no it's true
[Music]
that's so
uh trippy to me and i'll tell you why in
a second but why did you think of casey
becker from screening because
here was a woman who
um was being stalked
in her home
terrified
and i was prepping for it and
around the same time that i saw
you in that film and
your terror
was so
terrible it was so real it was so real
and i did i thought oh
that's that's it so i i i
you have made you have like justified
that entire performance i copied you
completely copied you okay well i think
i might surprise you right now and yet
it won't be when you look at it
oh
that was what i took to the wig maker i
said can you make me michelle pfeiffer
in scarface
you were my inspiration
that's why i tripped out so hard my head
is tingling
i
i want to find and i will make it my
life's mission of me dancing around as
stephanie zinoni my favorite movie in
the world grease 2.
that was right before i did scarface
you must not be able to like walk down
the street without people flipping out
about scarface that's a cultural
revolution it depends on where i am
if i'm in miami
um
or new york kind of east coast you know
there's a lot of big fans
but you know the mask
i love the mask
i i am never giving up the mask
okay well speaking of this area of your
face that leads to the head and the
heart and the memories and everything in
between
henry rose is something i think you hear
michelle pfeiffer and this beautiful
name henry rose which if you'll tell
everybody what that means because when i
found out it really touched me
basically i named the brand
after my the middle names of my children
um henry and rose and my daughter said
why isn't it rose henry
that's a good question i said because
men won't buy it
so it's a genderless brand
um
which is one of the many things i was
told not to do because nobody buys
genderless brands well now everything is
genderless you were so ahead of your
time and we took us about two years of
formulating once we started working to
launch with five fragrances and that was
um
two and a half years ago
and now it's going to be i think the
10th fragrance now we're coming out uh
yeah the 10th fragrance is coming out in
the spring we just launched our ninth
flora carnivora which is our first
true flora which was the really hard nut
to crack but i have a surprise for you
you do i do
i do
um
it's our sense since you are such a
fragrance connoisseur and such a fan of
fragrance
um this is our latest launch which we
just launched on monday
wait show the front
oh my god
okay this
packaging is
just so
incredible
this is stunning i mean not only do we
all love the rainbow and embrace it but
talk about including everyone well it's
so interesting because i thought of this
idea for the playground
and um and it kind of came out of our
our what what we were finding as a
company is that you know we have a
discovery set
um which is a sample set but what people
were doing is rebuying the discovery set
they were having so much fun
playing with them and layering them and
kind of creating which one did you do oh
my gosh i i
[Laughter]
oh
is it is it floral
yes
it's flora carnivora
am i gonna like eat myself
it's so beautiful
oh my gosh
oh my gosh okay um i am so excited
because um we're oh my gosh that you you
really you guessed me and you nailed me
[Music]
you